I'm excited I'm excited for the world to
kind of see the next chapter of my life
and that next chapter it's playing out
right in front of our eyes
yep that's sophie turner rocking her
baby bomb with a cute white maternity
dress grey shorts and a face mask the
mom-to-be was spotted taking a walk with
her hubby Joe Jonas her parents and
their adorable dogs in Los Angeles last
month a source told et that the couple
was trying to stay as active as possible
as the actresses due date approached
adding quote Joe and Sophie are excited
to be new parents and have been enjoying
the process of getting ready for their
baby and that the whole Jonas family is
looking for where it's a showering the
new addition with love our source says
Sophie is due soon and quote can't wait
to be a mom what time is it let's hurry
this down let's go it's show time it's
been a little over a year since Joe and
Sophie tied the knot Twice first in May
after the Billboard Awards in Las Vegas
with an Elvis impersonator and all and
then later in June where the couple had
a larger romantic ceremony in the South
of France for the most part the couple
has laid pretty low since including
through their entire pregnancy journey
which has played out amid the corona
virus pandemic ever during an appearance
on Conan in April Sophie did reveal that
she's really enjoying this time being
quarantined with her man everything
seems to be working out in my favor here
because Joe's like he's a real social
butterfly so I struggle to kind of lock
him down and I haven't just spent time
with me so it's kind of it's like prison
for him but it's great for me like
[Music]